Unter diesem Tuch steckt Fotografin
Sabine Alex.
Moderne Technik kann sie nicht begeistern:
Sie steht auf alte Kisten –
wie diese Großformatkamera,
mit der sie heute das Panorama
einer Berliner Straße ablichtet.
Jede Aufnahme –
eine überlegte Entscheidung.
Ich hab das Gefühl,
dass die meisten Leute eigentlich nur noch
durch ein Objektiv ihren Urlaub sehen
oder ihr Ereignis,
was sie gerade fotografieren.
Und seitdem ich das nicht mehr mache,
seitdem ich mich bewusst
für analog entschieden hab
geht es mir wesentlich besser.
Also das ist irgendwie so ‘n Druck,
der so weggeht.
Die 31-Jährige unterrichtet
analoge Fotografie –
von der Aufnahme
bis zum Entwickeln der Bilder.
In ihrer Werkstatt am
Berliner Ostkreuz
treffen sich jede Woche Fans
der alten Technik.
Was mir am meisten Spaß macht,
ist die
Entschleunigung
an der ganzen Sache,
dass man sich auf das
Wesentliche konzentriert.
Das ist halt nicht nur schnell Klick.
Und dann kann man auch nicht gleich sehen,
wie das Ergebnis ist,
und das ist ja grad das Spannende.
Für mich die Faszination an der
analogen Fotografie ist, dass es …
Es fühlt sich echt an,
dadurch, dass es physisch ist.
Also sie ist,
man kann es anfassen.
Es ist nicht etwas Abstraktes.
Das Interesse an analoger Fotografie
ist so groß,
dass sogar neue Modelle
auf den Markt kommen:
die „Reflex“ von einem
Londoner Start-up
ist die erste neue Rollfilmkamera
seit 25 Jahren.
Etablierte Hersteller setzen
auf Sofortbildkameras –
ein Foto kostet rund
einen Euro aufwärts.
Der bekannteste Anbieter – Polaroid –
war schon pleite.
Der Pole Oskar Smolokowski
hat die Firma gekauft
und 2017 eine neue Kamera
herausgebracht.
Die Zielgruppe:
Generation Instagram.
Jüngere Menschen reagieren so:
„Wow, das neue Teil ist toll.
Ah, okay, das gab es schon mal?“
Für sie ist es eine neue Erfahrung.
So ein Foto ist eins der wenigen
interessanten Dinge,
die außerhalb des Smartphones passieren.
Das spricht vor allem junge Menschen an.
Die Älteren sind immer noch
viel zu begeistert
von der einfachen Handhabung
und den technischen Möglichkeiten
digitaler Kameras –
und wie schnell man die Fotos teilen kann.
Mehrere Ausstellungen widmen sich
in diesem Jahr Instant-Fotos:
Im Wiener WestLicht „The Polaroid Project“
mit Aufnahmen von 300 Künstlern –
darunter Andy Warhol.
Die Londoner Photographer's Gallery zeigt
unveröffentlichte Bilder
des deutschen Filmemachers
Wim Wenders.
Er fotografierte seit den 1970er-Jahren
mit Polaroid.
Polaroids hatten so etwas Fröhliches,
Unbeschwertes.
Man hat sie einfach weggegeben.
Das Foto gehörte irgendwie mehr
der Person auf dem Bild
als der, die es machte.
Es war einfach Teil des Alltags –
man hatte etwas Schönes gemacht,
das man teilen konnte.
Der Umgang damit
war sehr unbekümmert.
Sabine Alex‘ Vintage-Kameras machen
auch mal Probleme:
Dann hilft Fototechniker
Michael Prügel.
Der Berliner hat sich auf das Reparieren
analoger Kameras spezialisiert
Unter seinen Kunden:
viele jüngere Menschen,
die nur noch mit digitalen Bildern
aufgewachsen sind.
Die kommen da manchmal
mit so ner uralten Box, ja.
Und wollen wissen, wie das funktioniert
und damit ein Foto mal machen,
und staunen,
dass wirklich dann ein vernünftiges Foto
bei rauskommt,
wo dann bloß bei digitalen
halt nur geknipst wird.
Es liegt in der Natur der Sache,
dass man nur die
wichtigen Momente festhält
während man mit dem Handy
sehr viele Fotos macht.
Bei analog geht es mehr darum,
was man aufnimmt –
und dabei auch mal
um die Ecke zu denken.
Bis Sabine Alex und die anderen
sich ihre Aufnahmen
anschauen können,
dauert es:
Zuerst müssen sie ihre Filme
mit Chemikalien entwickeln.
Und jetzt stellt ihr quasi alles so hin,
dass ihr‘s dann im Dunkeln auch findet.
Das Tüpfelchen,
was es halt unperfekt macht,
also so, so ‘n paar Stellen,
die so ‘n bisschen unscharf sind,
oder doch mal ein Fussel oder so was,
das, find ich, macht
eigentlich den Reiz aus.
Ob Rollfilm oder Sofortbildkamera:
Jedes analoge Bild ist
eine kleine Überraschung.
Die Generation Instagram hat den
fast schon vergessenen Zauber des Fotos
in der realen Welt wiederentdeckt.